So, let's now add in news case number 3.
Brewing is complete.
And started it up, its going and maybe the user pulled the pot or stuck
it back in or whatever, but we eventual got to the end, brewing is complete.
So, in this case, what, what, what steps do you expect to have happened.
>> So at this point we could assume that there should be coffee in the pot.
And if there's coffee in the pot, then we have that warmer plate that needs to
be activated to keep the coffee warm.
But I guess there's also the switch, the situation like you mentioned, the cup,
the pot could have been removed and then it's replaced.
So we got to do the check to see If,
I guess, there's still coffee there in the pot after brewing is complete.
But the boiler needs to be turned off, we're no longer boiling.
The water source is not really relevant anymore either.
I guess we need to somehow maybe prohibit our, well,
I guess you could start brewing again but.
I don't think that's an issue, I think I, I jumped to that being an issue, but
I don't think it is.
And then we need to turn on the light to say hey, there's coffee ready.
>> So we got that light there, so
we need to inform the user interface as to where the light lives.
So the one other thing that needs to go on is the containment vessel needs to
be informed because it keeps track of how much coffee remains in the pot.
And at the very start, the pot is full and
so it has to be told that the pot is full.
So there's a lot of messages and checks that have to go on here.
Let's let's add those into the diagram as well.